thank you for attending the sessions for
the track on empowering software
developers and mathematicians with next
generation ai
as we build future ai systems it's
important to design them so that they
are reliable correct predictable and
trustworthy so that they enable humans
to achieve more
from unlocking the creativity and power
of collaboration in developer
communities to creating tools for
solving formally specified problems
reliably in mathematics what you saw
today is just the tip of the iceberg
when it comes to amplifying human
potential in these areas and beyond
there's still more work to do
even though we only focused on software
developers and mathematicians today all
other fields of expertise are up for
disruption as well
can we use the power of deep reasoning
and ai to enable lawyers to design
ethical and fair laws
or help us discover new concepts in
economics or even solve open problems in
physics and other sciences
at microsoft research we have the unique
capability to lift our heads high in the
clouds while keeping our feet firmly on
the ground if you're interested in
working with the researchers you heard
from today please reach out to us we
would love to have you as our
collaborators interns and of course as
colleagues we hope to see you at another
microsoft research event soon